[Música]
senhoras e senhores pra mim é um
privilégio estar aqui com vocês a tarde
alegria mesmo eu já que era o de ante
mão então e responder a sua principal
pergunta meu respeito nesse exato
momento como empreendedor
a gente quer sempre nos antecipar então
nesse exato momento você está se
perguntando qual é a minha altura seu
jogo pensa o jogo vôlei eu jogo basquete
para os mais curiosos quanto total de
evitar que foi essa pergunta final do
evento eu tenho dois metros de altura
não jogo vôlei não joga basquete e para
os mais curiosos
aos 47 o interessante eu vou no shopping
comprar um sapato e aí quando encontra
um sapato 47 logo com dois ou três pares
saindo da loja as pessoas olham pra mim
acho que estou comprando um uma
televisão microondas algo assim tamanho
mas a parte 45 47 que é o caos mas eu
queria falar um pouquinho só vocês com
um mercado mercado de trabalho
eu já estou no mercado já há dez anos e
tenho pra mim que os nossos dias são
dias de extremas mudanças
me lembrou ainda que quando pequeno
passava as manhãs de sábado com a minha
mãe e os meus irmãos indo assim nós
conhecemos como locadoras para alugar
filmes assistir o final de semana aquele
mesmo filme que você esquecemos de
devolver no domingo à tarde
pois bem esse filme hoje você eu podendo
assistir netflix sem sair de casa
me lembro também que tantas outras
coisas que fazemos já mudaram
inclusive quando eu estava sentado neste
auditório quando fiz o curso de direito
aqui na milton campos assistindo
excelentes palestras e simpatiza pi sem
instagram sem facebook aqui nesse
auditório mundo mudou o mundo mudou
completamente
imaginem comigo dia em que vocês vão
chegar no restaurante preferido de vocês
e vamos fazer um pedido um tablet eee
tablet estará na mesa e stability estará
na mesa que você estiver sentado e um
robô com uma máquina um carro
lembro de controle remoto ou por que não
um drone vai chegar à sua mesa e vai te
entregar o seu pedido
até ontem isso parecia impossível
hoje eu não duvido de quase nada que
pode acontecer sim no mercado de
trabalho
então nós precisamos pesquisar sondar
refletir e de alguma forma nos inspirar
e aprender o chico mercado do século 21
procura
basta ter um monte de tomar basta ter
inteligência basta quem sabe fazer um
curso no exterior
basta falar inglês português basta de
alguma forma saber mexer no pacote
office
não sei eu quero um rápidos minutos
compartilhar com vocês aquilo que eu
tenho vivido e pelo menos duas
competências virtudes que acredito eu
serem essenciais para que você se firme
e se promova e cresça e se destaque no
mercado de trabalho do século 20 a
primeira delas eu aprendi cedo na minha
vida
imagina você ou com 12 anos de idade
indo para a escola ainda com 12 anos eu
levava aquilo que os alunos chamavam de
merendeira alguns de vocês vão se
lembrar disso aqui e eu levava
merendeira não sei como merendeira que
ela não vai levar a merendeira da escola
e aí chegava na escola 12 anos já quase
mais alto da escola com aqueles pés pra
dentro desengonçado pra frente a coisa
toda é horrorosa ainda levando a
merendeira verde-limão de coisa
maravilhosa impossível eu cheguei então
a negociar com o meu pai pai não dá mais
pra ficar levando merendeira da escola
né a gente quer conversar com outras
pessoas já aprenderam na faixa das
pessoas
então eu fiz uma barganha com o meu pai
negociou com o meu pai e comecei a
ganhar mesada lançado é bom demais
eu ganhava mesada para comprar o que eu
comia naquela época 1960 é coxinha de
frango catupiry com a cola 600 e meses
hoje o papa pensar eu quase cometi um
o crime contra minha própria saúde 96 da
manhã um adolescente com menos coxinha
de catupiry e uma coca cola era isso que
eu fazer de segunda a sexta
mas para ganhar apesar do meu pai ele e
nós combinamos em família de eu ter
algumas atribuições domésticos
você provavelmente já experimentou isso
aí de termos as atribuições da mesquita
entre elas eu tinha que diariamente
antes de ir à escola
pegar o jornal estado de minas o meu pai
acordava cedo tomar meu café e antes de
sair da minha casa então e até o portão
pegava o jornal e deixava o jornal na
porta do quarto do meu pai diariamente
se eu fizesse de segunda a segunda eu
ganharei a minha mesada para de segunda
a sexta comprar minha coxinha ea minha
coca cola
agora eu poderia simplesmente pegar o
jornal e ganhar mesada ou eu poderia
pegar o jornal
aqueles que lembram do que é um jornal
de papel sabem que ele vinha num
saquinho plástico
eu posso abrir esse saquinho plástico eu
posso colocar no caderno de esportes que
eu sei que é um caderno que meu pai
gosta de ler e eu posso deixar esse
jornal
do lado da cama dele de novo eu posso
pegar o jornal e deixar na porta do
quarto
ou posso pegar o jornal abriu saquinho
colocar na página de esportes e deixar
do lado da cama dele eu estou fazendo a
mesma coisa
ganhando a mesma mesada para comprar a
mesma coxinha e a mesma escola mas de
forma totalmente diferente isso o
mercado chama de um poder de superar a
expectativa das pessoas que estão ao seu
redor
o poder de surpreender nós precisamos
entender que o mercado de trabalho não
basta fazermos o que nos é pedido ou
fazer o que nos é solicitado
nós precisamos ir além precisamos fazer
mais
precisamos surpreender as pessoas
e por favor não confunda surpreender o
poder de superar a expectativa com entre
aspas puxa saquismo é muito diferente é
muito diferente superar a expectativa de
alguma forma você pode
fazer quando você faz o seu melhor
quando você é excelente o que é ser
excelente definição com gols de
excelência é você fazer o seu melhor nas
suas atuais condições
enquanto não tem condições melhores para
fazer melhor ainda o que é excelência
você fazer o seu melhor
enquanto nas suas atuais condições
enquanto não tem condições melhores para
fazer melhor ainda
então se eu e você saímos daqui dessa
tarde motivados e inspirados engajado em
fazer mais do que nos é pedido
mais do que nos é solicitado mais do que
é esperado da nossa própria atribuição
eu tenho certeza que de alguma forma
você começa a se destacar
onde quer que você esteja inclusive no
mercado de trabalho
é interessante que a gente alguns
precisam chegar agora de avião e tudo
quem conhece essa vida corporativa sabe
que a gente pega eu vou falar vou falar
nós estamos em nova lima onde eu moro
praticamente em frente à milton campos e
não raras as vezes contra um vôo pra mim
pra são paulo por exemplo seis e meia da
manhã às seis e meia da manhã em sair de
casa quatro e meia da manhã pra chegar
em confins em que meio da manhã para
embarcar seis e meia da manhã chegando
em confins que você faz em confins uma
hora 5 e 6 6 e 6 5 e meia da manhã
quem falou isso pede um café pede um pão
de queijo a nós meninos gostavam pode
que eu adoro pão de queijo e pede um
podcast pede um café pede um ipad um
suco de laranja eo pachuca mas prefiro o
suco de laranja você pede agora enquanto
80 em confins está trabalhando alegre
feliz sorridente cantando cinco e meia
da manhã lá em confins
aí você perde um similar àquela pessoa
um em pediu pediu vai vendo vai ver um
suco como é que o negócio é o suco é aí
a pessoa tá com suco aquele isso custa
r$10 garante sabe é 10 e ajudaram a
pessoa tá com o suco na sua frente cinco
reais de laranja vai embora né
as gotas de ajudar embora lambe o copo
para economizar que eles subissem
dez reais lá o grupo que agora você pode
chamar o gerente
você pode levantar pode xingar pode ir
embora
você pode de alguma forma entender
aquela pessoa de alguma forma deixou
quem sabe uma criança em casa está com o
marido desempregado tá com a situação
angustiante de ansiedade um problema
alguma circunstância negativa na vida
dela e você pode chegar até ela depois
tomar aquele suco de laranja que metade
derramou e ela pessoa de trato de alguma
forma esquisita e o mal e você pode
chegar até o chamado gerente ou você
pode alguma forma olha eu não sei que
você está passando
não sei como você está vivendo mas eu
quero te desejar um bom dia e os usaram
estava ótimo muito obrigado você e eu
seremos lembrados pela capacidade que
nós temos de surpreender as pessoas no
mundo de 6 bilhões de pessoas e você
repito seremos lembrados pela capacidade
de surpreendermos as pessoas que você
tem essa oportunidade
inúmeras vezes no seu dia a dia uma
segunda competência que eu não posso
deixar de falar da importância
principalmente o século 21 do que nós
chamamos de rede de relacionamento e não
é o facebook não é o instagram e muito
menos estou preocupado com quantos
grupos de outros a você está dentro
aliás grupo de usar uma coisa
maravilhosa que as pessoas inclusive
ficam chateados se não nos colocam nos
tiram do grupo de rap mas não é isso que
eu estou falando estou falando num mundo
onde particularmente ninguém tem tempo
pra nada e tempo é igual a dinheiro
se você quer ter tempo para alguma coisa
você vai no psicólogo no terapeuta
eles têm tempo para ficar te ouvindo ele
tem tempo pra ficar
de alguma forma ouvindo a sua sociedade
os seus medos e nós no nosso dia
infelizmente pais não têm tempo para
filhos filhos não têm tempo para pais
professores não têm tempo alunos alunos
não têm tempo de nada
nós vivemos reclamando nosso tempo
então vejam vocês como ganhar tempo na
apresentação de uma idéia de um projeto
de um sonho
se eu fosse te dar 10 minutos para me
apresentar a sua ideia o seu produto seu
projeto
você tem exatos 10 minutos para falar
alguma coisa que você gosta é uma coisa
que você queira me vender uma coisa que
você queira um investidor ou alguma
coisa nesse sentido
lá para os 7 minutos você pode começar
em uma fica ansioso que o seu tempo está
acabando o tempo é dinheiro e eu estou
indo embora
ou você tira da sua manga uma carta que
se chama rede de relacionamentos e você
fala assim essa pessoa fora sabe que me
mandou aqui não tem tema do dia todo o
país embora eu tinha vindo aqui a quito
embora
olha quem mandou que foi o fulano de tal
ranjith floridita comentava o edital
está bem demais a conta eu lembro
estudei com ele viajei com e casou num
casou
tá namorando ainda joga bola aquela
coisa do meu deus quantos aquela
conversa que tinha dez minutos para
durar
agora já tem 12 já tem 15 já tem 20 já
já vocês estão conversando sobre pessoas
em comum isso acontecer inclusive nesse
teste quando cheguei para fazer o
coaching com o nosso amigo tales não sei
se está aqui agora eu cheguei para fazer
o cutting com ele e ele me sentei na
mesa tempo corrido eu tinha que fazer o
corte com todos os outros
os quatro todos os outros palestrantes e
ele falou assim lucas
um amigo meu o lide pinotti conhece
gente coisa boa e estão conversando os
amigos em comum e o coaching que era de
15 minutos foi se alongando claro isso
se aplica quando a gente fala de vida
social conversar fiado um com os outros
mas também se aplica no mercado de
trabalho
quando você vai apresentar uma ideia
quando você apresentar um projeto quando
você vai apresentar um sonho pessoas
geram riquezas pessoas têm desejos
pessoas têm ambições pessoas têm sonhos
e portanto se aproximem das pessoas e
por que não começar aqui no ted
conhecendo uns aos outros
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]